LORNA GIBSON: So I think
one of the special things
about this course
and about my kind
of research on
cellular materials
is that I spend a fair
amount of time talking
about materials in nature.
So I talk about wood,
for instance, and what
it is about the cellular
structure that gives rise
to the density dependence
of wood properties
and the anisotropy
in wood properties.
I talk about
trabecular bone, and I
talk about the structure
and properties of the bone,
but also we do a
little bit of modeling
on how you might look at
bone loss and osteoporosis.
So if you lose a certain
fraction of the bone
density, what residual
strength would
you expect the bone to have.
We have a project
on bamboo right now.
We talk about the
structure of bamboo.
Bamboo is actually a grass.
And this is a Chinese species
of bamboo called moso bamboo,
and you can see how
big this one is.
They even get bigger, maybe
six or eight inches across.
And what we're
interested in doing
is making something called
structural bamboo products.
And this is an example of a
bamboo oriented strand board.
So the same way
people take wood,
and they chop wood
up into strands
and make oriented strand boards
for housing construction,
you could, in principal, do
the same thing with bamboo.
And we have a project
that's in collaboration
with some colleagues at the
University of British Columbia.
They're the ones
who are actually
making the bamboo
oriented strand board.
And with some architects in
England, in Cambridge, England,
we're looking at things like how
you might modify wood building
codes that talk about
wood structural products,
how you would modify that for
bamboo structural products.
And what we're
doing here at MIT is
we're looking at the
structure of the bamboo
and doing some modeling of
the mechanical properties
of the bamboo itself.
So that's one example.
Here's another example.
This is a bamboo laminate.
So this is a little bit like
a glue laminated wood member,
but in fact, this
one is made out
of bamboo instead
of out of wood.
So it's the same kind of idea.
Let's see.
We've also had a project
in the past on cork.
So this is a cork
from a wine bottle,
and we've looked at that.
Cork has an unusual
mechanical property.
You know, if you take a rubber
band and you pull on it,
if you can make it longer this
way, it gets narrower that way.
Well, if you load cork
in one direction, if you,
say, pull on it
or compress it, it
doesn't get any
wider or narrower
in the other direction.
It just stays the
same kind of size.
And you can show
that that's related
to the structure of the cells.
The cells are like
little bellows,
or like a little concertina.
So you can imagine if you
have a little concertina,
and you push on it this
way, it doesn't really
get any bigger that way
or smaller that way.
It just stays the
same dimension.
And the cork cells look
a little bit like that,
and that's why they do that.
So we have all these
natural materials.
We talk a little about
the hierarchical structure
in plants.
The cell walls are
fiber composites,
and then there's a
cellular structure.
And plant materials have a
sort of hierarchical structure,
with several different
levels of hierarchy,
and we talk about that
in the class as well.
And we talk a
little bit about why
that makes these materials
mechanically efficient
and how you might look
at designing engineering
materials based on that.
So there's a little bit of
biomimicking in the class
as well.